Our voicemail number is two one nine two David
p this call or wants to know how can we continue
to push progressive independent voices onto
larger and larger corporate media channels.
Take a listen.
Hi David.
On big fan of the show.
And I know a lot of people too, like when
are you going to debate?
Or like, when are you gonna go on Joe Rogan?
Things like that.
And I was wondering if there's anything we
can do as audience members to make that happen.
Whether it's like tweeting at certain people
or sending emails, um, that was already here
in Miami.
Yeah.
So listen, the answer is different with every
show.
So for example, I eventually got on Joe Rogan,
not because of all the people that tweeted
to him.
Apparently he doesn't like people tweeting
guest ideas at him and, or he also doesn't
look at anything other than the verified feed
if he's anything like me because it's just
a lot of nonsense happening on Twitter.
Uh, so eventually it was that Joe Rogan saw
a couple of my clips and eventually invited
me on.
I don't know the answer, but I think that
it would be really great if we continue to
politely tweet to Sam Harris and to Bill Maher
and to whoever else.
I don't think that it will hurt as long as
it's done politely.
Uh, right to the shows you want to see me
on.
As people know, I will appear anywhere that
there is an audience to be reached, whether
it's a political conservative, politically
conservative, politically liberal, nonpolitical
show, whatever.
And I'll continue doing the appearances as
long as the invite
keep coming.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Become a member or a patient, and to get instant
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com